well wait speaking of Dan's dad he told
a story about Dan the first time he was
at our show so let's see that yeah my
son was 15 and he was going to come with
us in Los Angeles we went down for the
premiere yeah of the movie and the night
before the premiere he he said uh he was
on a phone call with his friend back in
Toronto and they said well what's going
on he said well I'm going to the
premiere of American Pie uh tomorrow
night with my folks and the friend said
oh don't see it with your
folks did you not did you not go
no no absolutely not oh absolutely not
no I called a friend they had just seen
like an advanced screening of it and
said whatever run in the opposite
direction of wherever your parents are
in relation to that film and I did and I
never I have yet to see it with them I
did end up seeing it for most of my high
school life people thought the movie was
like a biography of my life
yeah that is
unfortunate is really unfortunate
because I would have killed to have had
a life that interesting um there was no
pie yeah I don't even know about the
ingredients of an apple pie but that's a
whole other
conversation um my I think my mother's
the opposite I would be fine I think in
that scenario I think my mother would
die okay I'm very open I'm very open I
will talk to my mother about
so will my sister and my mother hates it
wow like with a capital H okay yeah I
don't have that Dynamic oh my dad is
very sweet but no we there was no I have
no problem I can talk about anything
with her like literally anything and she
and I try but she is just not she is
like why your mouth is moving she's the
opposite of what this movie was to me
yeah she's not into it so I would have
gone to the premiere anyway your dad's
in a cool awesome movie I would have you
know it's like it's a weird thing to
grow up watching your dad just hand out
porn to some other
[Applause]
[Music]
kid thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home